sie kennen franz hohler und sie kennen
emil steinberger
die beiden kennen einander aber auch und
das sogar ziemlich gut und ziemlich
lange schon um so konnte jeder am
anderen beobachten wie dieser über die
jahre allmählich zum schweizerischen
volksgut wurde
beide hohler wie steinberger sitzen sie
nun am sternstunden tisch mit juri
steiner der will mit den zwei nicht nur
über die bedeutung des lachens in der
philosophie sprechen sondern auch über
die fährnisse der vaterlandsliebe und
über den unruhestand passionierter herr
steinberger erholung
wie haben sie sich eigentlich kennen
gelernt dass ich nicht so einfach zelle
weißt du durch das bestes gedacht ist
also brandes immer ja wieder anderen
worten wir sprechen hochdeutsch so hoch
wie es geht ja oft rice hat fragen sie
mich jetzt als erstes wenn sie noch
wissen ich glaube da muss ich passen in
eine diskothek glaube ich nicht
oder franz nein aber in einer ähnlichen
einrichtung neuer kleintheater luzern wo
du mich gebeten hat
nachdem du dieses theater eröffnet hat
ist oder eröffnen wolltest hast du
verschiedene leute gefragt ob sie
auftreten können unter anderem auch
nicht in einem sehr schönen brief das
war 1967 und ich bin damals schon sehr
jung schon aufgeteilt und dann haben wir
uns dort kennengelernt
also ich hab dich engagiert ohne dich
vorher gesagt wenn du du hast sozusagen
die katze im sack gekauft war es etwas
wie liebe auf den ersten blick dann oder
musste diese beziehung diese
freundschaft sich allmählich entwickelt
ich finde dass sofort der wahl so
so pflegeleicht im theater und wasser
gebracht hat das war pizzicato kann das
erste programm hat sich jetzt ändern
und das war ja herrlich und lustig kommt
die leute waren zufrieden also überhaupt
nicht
keine probleme die leute waren schnell
zufrieden aber ich habe in einer kritik
die auf ihrer webseite ist dass die 1970
er jahren gelesen über gabriel in acht
sprachen die kleinkunst ist wohl dadurch
fehlen zeit und sozialkritische aspekte
die dem kabarett das gepräge verleiht
über sie ich wollte noch schnell etwas
jahr beifügen zum kennenlernen
na ja da habe ich natürlich zuerst denn
den privaten e mail kennengelernt und
wusste aber schon dass er auch auftrat
und wenn ich mal was im radio gehört
hatte und war dann sehr neugierig weil
so
[Musik]
weil er sehr interessant war in seinen
äußerungen und im umgang und habe dann
gewartet bis er mal ein programm
gespielt hat und bin dann dieses
programm anschauen gegangen und hab dann
kam es dann auch zu einer zu einer
zusammenarbeit ja das andere ich habe
auf meiner website ausschließlich
schlechte kritiken über meine arbeiten
zusammengestellt damit die leute auch im
begriff zu kommen von den schattenseiten
des künstlerlebens und sehen dass wenn
das alles derart schlecht gewesen wäre
wie das beschrieben ist in diesen
ausschnitten dass ich das wohl kaum
überlebt hätten
aber das heißt sie hat noch
entwicklungspotenzial in den quartieren
vierziger jahre wahrscheinlich war es
gibt ja heute noch schlechte kritiken
heute habe ich nicht mehr viel
entwicklungspotenzial aber war dann
einfach die erwartungshaltung dass du
unbedingt politisches kabarett machen
muss das damals schon ja die also die
sprach jetzt aus diesen zitaten nämlich
und dazu muss ich sagen dass ich als ich
begonnen habe habe ich eigentlich dass
das waren das war ein fantasiegebilde
wenn meine ersten waren die ersten zwei
programme die da habe ich zum beispiel
einen hafner dargestellt
an das bild eines hafners der nacht zum
in dem museum erwacht und bisschen hart
gespielt und erzählt was er erlebt und
wir die leute sie die ihn sehen und so
weit also solche figuren habe ich
gebracht oder dann geiger der sehr gut
gespielt aber er hält die geige verkehrt
nämlich sowie einstellung der sollte
keine chance und das waren meine themen
und die ich habe erst später begonnen
nicht stärker politischen sagen wir mit
politischen reibungsfläche
auseinanderzusetzen
auch ihre kritik in einem anfang nicht
immer nur frenetisch sie haben auf ihrer
webseite ein paar ich drauf waren wurde
anfang ist ja sagen wir geschichten die
das leben schrieb also na ja allgemein
sei eigentlich nicht an einer anfang der
gegner klar zehn jahre weiter zurück
und ja da waren aussahen daten nicht
jeder so eine einzelne kritik bekommen
aber mein erstes programm das wir
zusammen machten geschichten die das
leben schrieb
da wartet titel emil langweilig primitiv
ohne pointen und zweiter kanal habe ich
ja beinahe sogar das war hart das war
hart haben sie da zusammen gelebt und in
dieser sich unglaublich an gerungen
ich habe die kritik gelesen wir es
schwarz geworden vor den augen
dann habe ich habe ich ihn ermutigt
nicht nicht darauf hören weiter machen
du musst höher was die wie die leute
reagieren das ist die antwort und das
publikum war so begeistert und kam ja ja
auch schon bei echten weiß zuversicht
die nächsten 30 vorstellungen jeden tag
ab geändert habe und verbessert und
setzte rausgeschmissen und das war ein
stehen also einen am 30 bei der 13
vorstellen zu besuch waren theater da
hat sie fast nicht mehr erinnern können
dass das gleiche programm war wie bahn
fahren also da wurde schon viel einfach
lustiger geändert werden es logisch weil
ich ja zu einer minderung der premiere
nicht alles auswendig im kopf habe und
dann passieren schon dinge die dann
später korrigiert werden müssen
heute ist halt so dass dieser nummern
dafür nun mann der ihre ihrer arbeit
wirklich volksgut geworden sind also die
haben wir alle im kopf quasi und wir
können wir können das toten überleben
kann ihre nummern auswendig sie sind
volksgut geworden institutionen können
dass dort die möbel aus wenn liegt das
ist aber
als kollektiv naja das war nicht viel
konnte dass jemand spontan vortragen das
war einfach so um dass repräsentativ zu
sagen aber quasi eben diese diese
präsenz von ihnen beiden im kollektiven
bewusstsein dass die institutionen sind
wie viel wie wie fest spielt das eine
rolle wenn sie sich treffen diese
vergangenheit
wir treffen uns so selten aber jedes mal
habe er großes vergnügen weil wir
spielen hat einfach die gleiche ebene
die wir haben also genau gleich
natürlich nicht nur wenn du schreibst du
dich was du schreiben kannst und wie du
schreibst ganz verrückt auf denke ich
der muss ja ständig mit einem
notizbüchlein rumlaufen wenn ich deine
wanderungen lese wenn da steht dann
zweigt die straße dann rechts ort wo man
da so das kannst du das aus im kopf
behalten beim liederschreiben oder
machst du das machst du am mikrofon dann
mache ich nicht da also ich glaube ich
etwas was mir im kopf geblieben ist und
das ist dann vielleicht das von dem ich
denke das ist das ist mitteilung
würdigte ich habe so sehr international
ja ja nein aber es ist sie fragten jahr
nach der beziehung oder wie die
vergangenheit eine rolle spielt die
vergangenheit spielt eine rolle
dadurch dass es sie wirklich gab oder
dass dass diese begegnung da war und
dann diese zusammenarbeiten dass man
auch doch dann zusammen gelitten hat
natürlich habe ich gelitten auch über
diese diese kritik und
ich mich sehr gut dann meine allererste
kritik erinnerte sich hatten
die war so schlecht dass waren an der
uni in der ersten und und rückblickend
denke ich eben das ist das ist gar nicht
das schlechteste was einem aus künstler
passieren kann
das ist wie ein initiationsritus nicht
das heißt wenn du diesen weg gehen
willst dann steht am anfang steht
irgendwann ball immer da und haupt die
fahrt in den magen und wenn das musst du
aushalten und wenn es nicht aushält dann
machst du besser was anderes sicher
schön wir können uns ja wiederholen und
verbessern und ich denke an ein
skifahrer der den ersten rang nicht um
eine hunderstelsekunde kam die abfahrt
nicht ja gesagt ich gehe doch mal hoch
ist nochmals besser noch einmal diese
diese aspekte der popularität die
flächendeckend ist in der schweiz und
dass sie wirklich einfach in dieses
volksgut gehören dass es eine eine
generation gibt die die auch schon
mobilisiert werden sie wieder erholen
sind archiviert in der landesbibliothek
sind sie reif fürs landesmuseum also
heißt das in eine andere art von
geschichtlichkeit in überwechseln
absolute haben ein letztes jahr oder
eine ausstellung über mich gemacht im
historischen museum sowie das gar nicht
realisiert und sind plötzlich im
historischen museum konfrontiert wurde
und jetzt ist ein weiterer plan in
luzern die möchten auch so etwas machen
ihn auch im historischen museum und ist
sehr lustig und dabei spiele ich diese
sachen die sie ausstellen spiele ich ja
ab und zu neue also das ist so das wort
museum ist da irgendwie beisitzers
falsche stoppen ist einfach der ort der
stadt findet fertig ja es kommt darauf
an wie man so eine ausstellung gestaltet
dass man also wieder lebendig machen
naja das
und anregend und interessant es gab über
mich mal eine ausstellung im strauhof in
literarischen museum oder muss ja im
literarischen museum sozusagen das
tatsächlich über meine arbeit mit
kindern und die war sehr lustig gemacht
und interessant ich habe auch viel
beigesteuert material aber aber da und
bin öfters sind diese ausstellung
gewesen habe mit kindern zusammen
geschichten gemacht zum beispiel und kam
mir da dann eigentlich nicht speziell
museal vor sondern dachte auch das ist
so kann man ausstellungen machen ohne
dass das wort museal jetzt etwas
verstaubtes bekommt zum begriff volksgut
gehört der begriff gut auch sehr wohl
haben mal über emil gesagt dass emil der
schweiz gut täte weil er etwas
verbindendes habe sie selbst haben diese
verbindende nicht immer so einfach
gehabt
es gibt momente wo sie auch ein bisschen
gespalten haben oder zum teil sogar sehr
gespalten hatten wir haben einen kleinen
ausschnitt aus dem film von tobias wies
der letztes jahr gedreht wurde zum
siebzigsten geburtstag da jetzt in einer
langfassung in die kinos kommt holger
frank und da möchten wir kurz
reinschauen
auch wenn sie am sonntag mit den kindern
wandern von einem jura gibt für zum
andern dann hören sie vielleicht hinter
sich einen schritt und ziehe ich bin's
und wanderer mit ich bitte sie wirklich
fühlen sie sich freien doch merken sie
sich einfach ich bin dabei liebe
familien wie gibt es hallo ich hab so
deren kinder als restrisiko steinbergen
zu dieser franz hohler oder schweiz gut
tat damals besonders gut natürlich
natürlich nicht alles gut goutiert von
allen seiten da hat er ja kämpfen wissen
und leiden müssen und man hat dich aus
gespart und oder die sendung wurde
verboten gestrichen oder also damals war
so das war brisant damals hätte man das
ja man hört es einfach und nimmt das
entgegen und der alltag geht fast weiter
gefährlich das war doch damals so naja
mutig von dir ja du kommt es gar nicht
haben
das war deine sendung als parteien
gedankengut das ist die dachhaut
geöffnet hast also ich hab es nicht dass
mutige funden aus dass helmut ich selber
nicht achte ich wollte einfach meine
eben meine
eine satirische nummern machen oder
meine oder auch eben das ist ja seiner
satirischen fernsehsendungen glaubens
das sagen übrigen aber die vor allem die
denkpause von 80 bis 83 diese satirische
sendung die hat ziemlich polarisiert
weil sie eben auch noch mitten im kalten
krieg war wo man sehr rasch dann in die
ganz linke ecke gestellt wurde wenn man
irgendetwas kritisch ist über die über
das bankgeheimnis sagte zum beispiel
oder oder was immer dann dann wurde man
wurde war ziemlich rasch haben ist auch
in die linke seite aufgeschoben oder
eben nicht das militär das war ja damals
der knackpunkt der zum ende führt diese
sendung weil eine sendung über das
militärische denken die ich aufgenommen
hatte und die mit dem lied dienst
verweigert änderte die meine mundart
versionen von boris wie aus die sagte
die würde nicht ausgestrahlten darf ich
gesagt wenn ich das was ich 50 mal auf
der bühne gesungen habe nicht am
fernsehen spielen oder singen da habe
ich dann kann ich diese sendung nicht
mehr
also das heißt sie haben gemeinsame
anfänge sie hatten fand ohne einmal als
weichensteller auch bezeichnete sich der
zehn jahre jüngere von solitaire ihnen
geholfen hat sich selbst da hat mir
gesagt
neben wer hat diese nummer geschrieben
dass du einmal gesehen aus der putsch
hat habe ich selber geschrieben hat du
bist doch alles zu beschreiben
das kannst du so und da hast du mir
einfach ein tor geöffnet
sie diente mir vertrauen gegeben hat und
dabei was als wir die ersten blumen
geschrieben haben könnte art und auf
tonband aufgezeichnet haben
naja eigentlich gar nicht geschrieben
sondern ja sie entwickelt er
improvisieren was ja immer auch deine
stärke waren nicht und dann und danach
vom mit mit einem tonband und danach
sollten uns die stellen gemerkt die die
man gut verknüpfen können miteinander um
die dann sie dann eine nummerierung das
ist einfach so schön ich meine seinen
sendungen wie übrigens oder so oder so
politisch war
ich habe einfach ganz anders
kennengelernt einmal so lustig und
fröhlich und hat am humor so viel spaß
und das war ja herrlich diesen tagen
kein theater wir haben so viel lachen
können und trotz hat man nicht entdeckt
ein franz dass er das auch hat sondern
er war dann einfach du was dann einfach
politisch eingeteilt und hart eingeteilt
worden und das andere konntest du gar
nicht ausspielen na ja vielleicht sogar
der bogen schauen ich habe ja auch die
politischen nummern die waren ja auch
die waren ja auch spielerisch und jungs
also ich habe ja nicht gepredigt hat
aber die spieler sich wenn man es jetzt
ganz einfach quasi schubladisieren
müssten dann wären sie eher der
politisch satirische und sie werden der
leichte und harmonische und dann könnte
man ja fragen sie als weichensteller
auch wie viel wie viel franz hohler war
dann in der figur ja das ist schwer zu
sagen das ist
ich meine die figur war früher schon
geprägt worden aber ich einen milchmann
gespielt oder oder einer der im
vereinskassier oder ich weiß nicht als
und es war so dass sich das sagen ich
bin es einfach selber und das hast du
gespürt ich muss gar nicht lernen ich
probier auch nie ich kann nicht probe
ich gehe nicht für mich auf die bühne
zehn tage vorher und spiel das durch das
kann ich gar nicht sondern das kommt
einfach die mimik kann ich auch nicht
studieren die sehe ich ja selber gar
nicht
es ist einfach weiß nicht wie du das
heißt mit und du sagst aber dass mich
erlebt
es kommt einfach sporadisch
ja ich denke es braucht nicht viel
franz hohler um emil entstehen zu lassen
oder entstehen war ja schon da aber um
emil zu mehr figur zu verhelfen
das war eigentlich nur die ermutigung
dass dass er das dass er das kann und
dass wir dass wir das auch mit
gemeinsamen vorgaben beim rennen wenn
ich dann den partner gespielt habe sagen
wir das kind das fragt wie ein flugzeug
flieger und im verkehrsmuseum und das
konnte man nachher weglassen damit war
ich auch wieder raus und weg und e-mails
standorten das hat sie nie gekünstelt
das politische aus der aktion weil ihre
flügel und waren ja auch lokalpolitische
waren lokalpolitischer gewann
ja ich also ich würde sagen es gebe
gewaltige themen politische geben ganz
bestimmt aber ich kann es nicht mischen
sie kann nicht einmal so einer spiel-
und dann wird er politisch da das müsst
ihr so ganz haarscharf ineinanderfließen
dass das funktionieren wird
aber das möchte ich gar nicht ich habe
gern wenn die leute einfach lachen und
sich unterhalten können und sich selber
vielleicht schon natürlich resultate wo
die leute sagen seit ich sie auf der
bühne gesehen habe ein täglich überall
auch zu menschen die sich so benehmen am
schalter oder da oder dort und das finde
ich schön und dann lachen sie früher
haben sie sich aufgeregt vielleicht zu
sagen typisch emil und so das ist dann
meine einem eine botschaft wenn man das
so nennen will
zugleich muss man ja sagen nein sie
fragten ob ich ob ich ihn nicht mehr
denken wollte dass er politische wird in
seinen nummern und ich fand das ist
einfach nicht das ist nicht seine eben
seine bohnen oder das ist nicht seine
natur oder das ist nicht dass das ist
nicht das was auf der bühne wirkt bei
ihm weil neben der bühne habe ich immer
als politisch engagierten menschen
erlebt wir waren auch zusammen bei
veranstaltungen für die kulturinitiative
damals getötet hat
die politik will ich nichts zu tun haben
aber politik auf der bühne waren nicht
das wahre habe ich einfach nicht sein
ding weil auch nicht angemessen gewesen
und habe ich dann umgekehrt und stelle
fragen wie viel
100 jährige hat das gesagt hat das
spielerische verbunden denke wir sind
wir sind beides spielernaturen und auch
das komödiantische ich habe ja auch
immer gern figuren gespielt dass er
dadurch die diese dieses restrisiko
vorhin das war ja auch das war eine
bühnenfigur eine etwas unheimliche ich
habe immer das etwas unheimliche gemacht
nicht der theaterdonner oder theater
naja das war er hat ja etwas geglückt
ich habe einen einen eine figur gespielt
werde den donner macht dem theater nicht
gleich ja das war ein bisschen eine
könnte sie was können sie uns ein 1 1
msp situation zeigen neben zum was das
was jetzt gesagt hat ich komme auf die
bühne mit einem großen blech und mit
einer mit schuhen mit wattierten schulen
oder kunststoff so kunststoff bälle
drauf sind und stelle dann und erzähle
den leuten wie man den dollar macht und
der c und zeige dass dann auch und wie
zum beispiel im das im freischütz zwei
gewitter von entgegengesetzten seiten
kommen auf die bühne zu und dann habe
ich links ein kleines blech und rechts
ein größeres und die figur des am
schluss sagt er eben jetzt das wäre
jetzt
viele elektronisch gemacht also man
länger als den digital download und das
sei natürlich nicht dasselbe
und dann spürt man und ist gelöst dass
niemand spielt das ende dieses sommers
nicht ja und die und dann wird dazu eine
figur die die er hat die die verliert
oder die zurücktritt und man man sieht
hat auf die dauer keine chance an
gespaßt ja da auch bei emi würde ich
sagen gibt es solche figuren auch die
der emil spielt oft die verlieren oder
eben die überfordert und sagen also die
durch diese realität überforderten einer
meiner lieblings nehmen ist wie der
kiosk am 1
wo eine wo der anruf dass pro toto
gesellschaft und sie müssen noch einiges
nachtragen für einen kunden und dann sei
ja das überhaupt nicht in frage
das machen müssen als dann gute
kundenverhaltens polizeilich verboten
wir haben da eine andere polizei am
schluss als das ist für mich ein absolut
metaphysisches jahr hatten sagte wenn
gut wenn sie das nicht machen dann
müssen sich die konsequenzen ziehen und
ich werde in zukunft ihr mann anderen
berücksichtigten gegen sie alle gemein
das nächste mal werde keine anträge zu
einer anderen gesellschaft besitzen
das hört das ist eine these dass das ist
ein großartiges schluss weil es eine
ganz kleine trage die bin ich eine
comedy weil es ist chancenlos nicht das
ist derart chancenlos
und er ist so tapfer und setzt sich so
ein den kunden ja diese diese absurdität
dass das reale dass hinter diesem
schweizerischen normalbetrieb permanent
lauert und wo wir uns ja auch
offensichtlich wieder erkennen sonst
hätten sie an diese diese erfolge gar
nicht gehabt
und leben können es gibt ein beispiel
bei ihnen holen das mich sehr fasziniert
hat nämlich ihr flug nach milano das ist
19 84 glaube ich ein flugzeugentführer
namens herr franz entführt ein flugzeug
nach milano richtung genf weil er das
gefühl hat die schweiz sei nicht mehr am
leben und dürfe jetzt nicht mehr oder
nicht mehr lebendig die finde ich mir
die schweiz heissen sondern müsse das
schweiz heissen und das ist natürlich
dann nicht mehr der kiosk am meisenweg
sondern das ist dann wirklich zündstoff
auch oder die frage nach der identität
terrorismus als thema die würde dieser
terrorist franz 2014 was würde
erforschung es ist eine hypothetische
frage weil die figur war von 1984 und
das war dass die die thematik war von
damals aber natürlich natürlich und ich
würde das kaum mehr so machen
wahrscheinlich bin ja 30 jahre weiterhin
sich nun 30 jahre ältere drehte gar
nicht mehr auf mit bühnenprogrammen
nicht aber natürlich ist der
normalbetrieb von heute hat genauso viel
absurd dass wieder normalbetrieb
1993 er hat genauso viel auch
lebensfeindliche elemente die ich damals
wie ich damals kritisiert habe es
braucht gar nicht viel bis man um sich
zu vergegenwärtigen dass man das unter
dem normalbetrieb die die groteske lauer
nicht und was immer noch so ist es wird
jede minute jede sekunde wird ein
quadratmeter land überbaut bei uns gehen
jedes jahr 1000 bauernhöfe verloren
wir haben mehr autos aus kinder in der
schweiz wie auch die die mobilität hat
ein ausmaß angenommen
ein gigantisches ausmaß wenn man im zug
sitzt dann klappen alle klappen ihre
laptops auf und arbeiten weiter wie die
wahnsinnigen wir sind dann fahren das
volk die wand sich als sie arbeiten ja
manchmal ich sehe auch das ist die
gucken auch filme vielleicht schauen sie
sich auch der fürstenberger diese diese
konstanz die ist jetzt ein bisschen
beschrieben haben also dass wir immer
noch soll ich sagen
im gleichen spital krank sind wie in den
80er jahren und uns sich der
normalbetrieb auch wie festhält haben
sie haben sie das gefühl es gibt dinge
die sich aus geschaffen haben in den
letzten 20 30 jahren die nicht mehr
schweizerische es gibt viele alltägliche
sachen die sich sehr geändert haben das
fängt sogar bei der religion an was ich
da ich aus als zehnjähriger wenn ich mir
am morgen die zähne geputzt habe man um
mir ist ein bisschen zahnpasta die kehle
runtergerutscht
dann durfte ich schon nicht mehr in die
kirche gehen und die kommunion zu
empfangen
nutzte nüchtern sein meint das war
extrem
aber das war so und was ich da allein
auf diesem wird jeden freitag ist ja und
kein fleisch isst das war ja knallhart
durchgezogen worden
jeden sonntag musste in den gottesdienst
gehen das ist nur auf dem sektor
religion macht sich da schon alles
gewaltig verändert habe ich finde das
eigentlich wahnsinnig toll also uns
menschen gegenüber das menschliche
geworden das ganze aber dann gibt es
auch heute gedacht als sie dann zu uns
die zeitung gelesen habe also irgendwie
müssen wir den menschen wieder mal dran
nehmen das ist ja grausam was da alles
von menschen einfach gemachten falsch
gemacht und gelogen und beschissen und
betrogen und also gemordet und als er 17
war ist unglaublich und wir reden kann
über den menschen reden nur über politik
für die ihre fehler machen aber was wir
für fehler machen im alltag oder
überhaupt ich habe mal weil ich das buch
geschrieben habe war die
lügengeschichten habe ich mal ein fahrer
gefragt was machen sie mit dem thema
lügen war drehten sie auch mal übers
lügen und so ist für uns überhaupt kein
thema weil wir nicht das ist fliegt das
sind doch die die da fängt doch schon am
mit der misere wenn man sich an liegt es
natürlich zu robust wie heute kann man
ja das sehr gut feststellen wäre ein
anderer an liegt auf dem höchsten
politischen gipfel schonen und das kommt
ja auch von unten also ja ich würde eher
dahin etwas orientieren mehr auf den
menschen
ich bin ja eigentlich immer mehr den
menschen darstellte gewesen und zwar
wahrscheinlich immer aber es war aber
auch immer schon auch konnte man sich
selber auch eindecken darin ja aber das
heißt es waren seine eine
kleinbürgerliche auf spießige schweiz
die sie ja ein bisschen
aufgestachelt haben wir auch wenn man
sich die nummern e mail an post eine
gemeinsame arbeit an scheint dann hat
man das gefühl man lacht zwar noch aber
er ist da man schon mal sagen für ein
jahr bei zusammen das war schon ein
vergnügen also willkommen ich denke wir
kommen beide also aus einer welt die die
eng war die schweiz die wir vielleicht
fast noch mehr als ich war ein bisschen
älter ist aber nicht auch noch nicht
weiß die die eng war auch eine schweiz
die in der es zum beispiel verdingkinder
gab in der es diese aktion kinder der
landstrasse gab die die davon ausging
dass das fahrende kein normales leben
führen dass man die kinder den fahrenden
wegnehmen muss und in feste
pflegefamilien in mit festem wohnsitz
verpflanzen müssen damit sie anständige
menschen werden und damit furchtbar
biographien produziert hat es gab muss
man auch wieder neues ich vergeben
werden es gab kein frauenstimmrecht als
ich zum ersten mal abstimmen ging waren
da nur länder und das ist heute wenn man
das heute jungen menschen erzählt oder
jungen frauen die können das fassen kann
sich das nicht vorstellen hat sich durch
schnappen freude wenn man das sagt wir
haben jetzt das stimmt dann lachten die
haben ja ja dass wir so in der herr
henke
aber sie wussten ja auch nicht abstimmen
gleich bei einem thema das das eine der
konstanten bildet unser verhältnis zu
den ausländern und unser verhältnis zu
den deutschen und seit dem 19 februar
wissen wer einmal mehr das ist nicht ein
einfaches verhältnis ich finde da gibt
es fast wieder einen umbruch rückwärts
ich meine es ging uns ja wirklich jetzt
also gut die letzten 20 jahre vor lagen
sogar ja sage ich mal großer motor und
jetzt beginnt eine tochter ihr quasi
jetzt drehen wir das rad wieder zurück
und wollen sehen wo das durchgehend habe
keine ahnung wo das durchgehen werden
aber auf der anderen seite glaube ich
kapieren wir einfach nicht dass werden
nie mehr sagen können wer schweizer die
sind einfach unter uns das gibt es doch
gar nicht mehr dass wir einfach
international sind wir haben alles bei
uns im land werden von allen kontinenten
der welt gibt es leute bei uns leben und
die bringen ihr auch ideen und alles
oder werden diese mischung ist noch gar
nie akzeptiert worden
und die kann man ja gar nicht also was
würde man sicher dass dort auf hauses
vorstellen
dieses rad zurückdrehen das ist
überhaupt nicht mehr möglich dürfen wir
es trotzdem kurz versuchen nämlich mit
einem kleinen film ein spieler von den
schweizer machen
1978 einer der größten oder wenn ich der
größte kinoerfolg der schweizer
filmgeschichte eine komödie
1978 von rolf lyssy russland fortsetzen
wird
damit der bürger unserem land werden
wir müssen sie neutral 30
trotzdem ist das gerade sehr zuverlässig
richtig einfach reifer jawohl integer
ehrlich und zuverlässig was man sonst ja
wir legen großen wert auf regelmäßige
kommen aber ich glaube ich wäre doch mit
30 billig billig raum und soll will ich
sie aber es gibt noch zwei wichtige sie
sehen hier ein geschafft musste russland
station machen
ich stelle mir vor was ihr habt da ich
bin spitze halten müsste mir das habe
unter beweis stellte mit aus alles als
der herrscher waren sie lachen jetzt
also sich einzeln zumindest wir haben
sie das gefühl hat sich die schweiz
weiter bewegt seit 78 wenn sie diesen
ausschnitten sichern
gut ich musste nie eingebürgert werden
und deshalb kann ich nicht sagen wie es
heute ist wenn man wirklich eingebürgert
werden will weil ich höre dann von
leuten die sich einbürgern lassen wollen
dass sie doch überraschend besuch
bekommen von der von der behörde
damit sie beurteilen können ob man ein
würdiges mitglied unserer gesellschaft
werden könnte unsere schweizerischen
gesellschaft und ich hoffe natürlich
schon dass ich das ein bisschen tasten
geändert hat
aber das herz das sage ich habe einmal
den fragebogen bekommen das ist für eine
mappe von wo die ausländer in einer
zürcher gemeinde beantworten müssen
das ist ja unglaublich was sie wissen
müssen dass weiß ja kein
durchschnittsschweizer kann diese fragen
beantworten und das wird von den
verlangt und das finde ich allein schon
das absolut unmenschlich und wir wissen
ja alle die in der schule alles was wir
auswendig lernen mussten vergisst man ja
wieder
und da sind ja auch alles zu begriffe
was ist proporz reinschreiben was ist
platz das weiß er vielleicht in dem
moment noch aber nachher eigentlich mal
was wir vor allem wenn es das verfahren
wenn es in gang kommt das ist eine sache
aber dass das verfahren überhaupt in
gang kommen kann wer hat mir eine
einbürgerungs initiative vor ein paar
jahren erleichterte einbürgerung und die
wurde abgelehnt auch mann oder was man
sehr oft hört ist das leute türkischer
herkunft abgelehnt werden bei der
einbürgerung hingegen wenn sich ein
deutscher oder ein österreicher einfügen
lassen will wird viel eher angenommen
dass leute die aus dem bau kam sind und
30 jahre hier wohnen dass die nicht
aufgenommen werden ohne dass irgendetwas
gegen sie vorliegt und ich meine dort
tat sich dann wieder die enge die alb
engel der schweiz nicht mal vor ich habe
eine frau geheiratet die kommt aus köln
wir leben in motto meine frage muss sich
jedes jahr bei der einwohnerkontrolle
melden
und die haben immer entschieden dass sie
bleiben oder nicht
obwohl sie gehöre mit mir verheiratet
ist also die werden im stande gewesen
meine frau zu sagen gehen sie wieder
zurück nach deutschland und unsere ehe
getrennt also ich meine solche
vorstellung die duh mieter lebst
spinnen wir eigentlich sonst
sie haben erwähnt also als wir kurz bei
ihrem flugzeug terroristen waren also
die überwachung der dichte stress sie
haben das begriffen ich genommen aber es
gibt etwas wo wir weiter an unserer
schweiz auch leiten und das fokussiert
sich dann halt in diesen abstimmungen
auch auf diese bevölkerungszuwachs raten
die enorm sind die uns offensichtlich
stressen und wie könnte man diesem
stress abhilfe geben kann man es mit
humor kann man hätte eher schwierig also
ich meine ich denke ja oft ich wenn ich
in deutschland bin sagt diskutiert man
auch über demokratie und so und dann
sage ich natürlich ja ihr könnt ja nicht
abstimmen und sagen wir wir sind froh
dass wir nicht abstimmen dürfen
wir wissen doch auch diese materie nicht
wir können uns da sage ich hat ja in der
schweiz wir müssen zeitung lesen wir
haben am fernsehen gut die sendung
diskussionssendung wir hören politiker
an wir uns weiter wir schauen uns zu
diesem themen wo wir an die urne gehen
müssen und dass das haben wir auch nein
das sind wir deutsche viel zu dumm dazu
drei grausames urteil finde ich ganz
schritt waren zum voraus dass sagt wobei
wenn ich jetzt denke dass wir bald über
flugzeugbeschaffung abstimmen müssen
die dich das schon verrückt ich meine da
ist reine eine militär taktik dahinter
oder eine luftüberwachung taktik
dahinter oder ich weiß nicht was für
taktiken die ja eigentlich geheim
gehalten werden müssen und da sollen wir
kleinbürger sagen was richtig ist ob wir
diese flugzeuge wollen oder liegt es
schon ein bisschen paradox angeht
aber nicht um die strategie oder
natürliche das militär dürfen ja auch
abstimmen wollen wir sollten immer das
kommt auch wieder das finde ich als
sensationell auf der welt welches land
wo kann ein volk abstimmen gehen ob sie
das militär wollen ich finde das
sensationell
ich wundere mich immer wieder über die
für die demokratie eben auch über das
vertrauen in die halte auch wenn ich
gewisse vorlagen dann anschauen ein
neues jagdgesetz im kanton zürich und
das sind 24 seiten zum beispiel der
biber ja aber die machen doch auch
schäden die bieter soll man jetzt den
gezielt abschließen und so weiter also
alle diese natürlich kann man sich da
eine meinung bilden und ich finde auch
ich finde es im prinzip ein großes
vertrauen in den menschen das dahinter
steckt und dass der mensch hätte nichts
was wir nicht zu dumm sind um unseren um
uns ein urteil zu bilden obwohl es in
sehr vielen dingen um
und um sachgebiete gehend mit denen wir
überhaupt nicht vertraut sind
ich habe in einem verein deutsche
zeitung zum ersten august ein artikel
gesehen
berlin habe ich aufgezählt was wir in
der schweiz in der samstags sonntag
alles abgestimmt haben
in der schweiz in den gemeinden in den
kantonen das war so eine verrückte liste
wenn du sonst als schädlinge die sich
binnen ja überall das muster an die urne
gehen und rechenschaft ablegen und sein
wissen bekunden dass du das weißt und
weil soll ich ja oder nein oder die
million bestimmen oder weiß gott was ist
schon ein ganz einmaliges system
natürlich und dann kommt natürlich zum
beispiel die kulturellen abstimmungen wo
immer die kultur welt zittert ob ich
weiß noch die wie in basel darüber
abgestimmt wurde ob man das so binde
kaufen wolle und habe einfach noch nicht
lange her aber ja wir sind vertragen
sie wissen das alles noch nicht und das
wurde angenommen damals und picasso war
begeistert und hat sich der stadt also
darum viel geschrieben aber auch die
kulturinitiative zum beispiel die die
keiner geschafft die war die wahlchancen
lohn oder eben wenn irgendwo wieder
abstimmen bevor sie über übers
opernhauses subventionen oder dann wenn
man die diskussion verfolgt über den
hafenkran da in zürich dann sieht man
einfach dann dann hat man oder auch über
die buchpreisbindung aus beispiel von
über das noch nicht so lange her ist
dann
hat man als kulturschaffende auch nicht
ein spezielles vertrauen in das volk aus
der erfahrung heraus dass kultur
eigentlich fast immer eine sache der
minderheit ist und dass ich nie eine
mehrheit für kulturinteressierte aber
sie beide haben das jahr exemplarisch
geschafft eine eine kultur kultur zu
machen für mehrheiten für viele nicht so
funktioniert als kmu s wie sie das mal
gesagt haben keine sponsoren hat ja auch
keine spansion nein oder manchmal wenn
man das gab die zeit als plötzlich das
sponsoring das private aufgaben und dann
hast du eine eintrittskarte für eine
vorstellung von dir umgedreht und herauf
waren die drei schlüssel der
bankgesellschaft
das war eine ansicht aus zum ersten mal
gesehen
das war kleiner kulturschock
haha was ich werde oder die institution
aber heute ja ist es ist allgemein
üblich ja und es ist ein teil
es ist eine ergänzung der öffentlichen
hand und das ist ja auch nicht im
prinzip schlecht du musst die neue wahl
überlegen ob das eine institution ist
die die dir gefällt oder die duh
unterstützen wird ist der weg zum
beispiel eine institution die sie
unterstützen könnten aktuell vielleicht
präsenz schweiz die image agentur der
schweizer weil wir ja ein bisschen
nachholbedarf haben das ist ein gebiet
ich wahr gemacht in 1990 habe ich eine
große werbe tour in deutschland gemacht
für die schweiz die hieß schweiz plus
und da hab ich gedacht da will ich jetzt
nicht mit kühen und kuhglocken kommen
und nur wenn man mit schokolade sagen
dann wenn die leute da in den grad der
reingekommen sind dann wurden sie
begrüßt von einem bankier der zaubern
konnte da hatten deutschen wenn die
einen euro scheinen reingeschoben habe
oder ein d mark damals hat er ein
maschinen geräte und dann sind dann
schweizer franken ralf gekommen oder da
war eine
frau das attraktiv angezogen mit einem
bauchladen da kommt die leute hingehen
und der schweiz müssen sie 15 am
richtigen ort einsetzen und so da war
dann war das thema kunst und aktuellen
modell gemalten einfach dann einmal von
einer ganz anderen seite und das war
sehr gut aber gemerkt hat man es sowieso
ist bei der werbung man merkt sofort
wenn dann steckt er wohl dass sie ja gut
ich denke sobald man aus künstlerin
ausland auftritt ist man immer auch ein
botschafter oder man wird immer auch aus
der schweizer wahrgenommen merke ich
auch jetzt nach der ich hatte
verschiedene lesungen nach der
abstimmung ich habe auch ein text
gemacht darüber einen satirischen den
ich vortrag wie geld was jedes mal
darauf angesprochen das heißt ich bin
ein ansprechbarer vertreter dieses
landes wenn ich im ausland bin aber ich
denke ich würde ich würde die verbindung
am ehesten über die kultur suchen
es war kürzlich war eine gruppe von
deutschen medien leuten in die schweiz
eingeladen worden im vorfeld der
buchmesse leipzig wo die schweiz als
offizielles gastland auftritt wollte man
den die schweizer etwas zeigen also dass
sie wissen wer da kommt
und ich wurde gefragt ob ich mit diesen
diesen medienleuten einen literarischen
spaziergang durch zürich machen würde
und das habe ich gemacht und bin mit den
habe ich eine kleine runde gemacht in
der innenstadt von von der wohnung von
hugo loetscher über das gab er wollte er
bis zu der münchner wohnung und lenin
daneben und den kopf im keller und zum
max frisch brunnen am rosenhof platz und
und das denke ich dass das wäre meine
möglichkeiten die die schweiz aus jetzt
die schweiz aus teil einer als teil
einer kulturellen landschaft auch
darzustellen oder aus als als teilt auch
aus teil der welt wie du gesagt hast
nicht wissen will nur ein bestandteil
und 7
wir haben eine sehr reiche kulturelle
landschaft finde ich bin verblüfft wenn
man in deutschland ist was deutsche mehr
erzählen wo sie in den urlaub gehen also
die entdecken ja die hintersten
ortschaften irgendwo schwärme davon und
sagen ich war in grüne kuriere zum
beispiel als kann oft namen nicht genau
das ist abscheulich aber dass die
entdeckten so unglaublich die schweiz es
ist denke ich also die sind teilweise
schon fast verliebt in die schweiz die
findet das land schon schön teuer ist
als andere ein anderes thema da können
wir ja noch viel verbessern oder eben
nicht ich weiß es gab einmal eine
diskussion am radio
man sagt immer die österreicher sind so
freundliche gastfreundlicher und da war
der schweizer tourismus direktor dabei
und da hat gesagt ja das sind wir
einfach nicht wir können das nicht die
österreicher sind von natur aus einfach
freundlicher und so das können wir gar
nicht lernen wir also was war voriges
jahr nicht jetzt aber gedacht mensch
dass das ja gar nichts sagen das kann
man
lernen das muss man auch lernen ja
sollte man ich werde obwohl er auch
haben ja auch gar kein kaum
einheimisches personal ist überall her
aber könnte nicht freundlich sein welche
die sprache ja gar nicht sehr viel
deutlicher ausländische leute im
tourismus aber das ist natürlich ein
weiteres phänomen das wir auch eben zu
der schweiz von heute wir neben unserem
haus ist ein bauplatz da wir dann wieder
mehrfamilienhaus gebaut das was sich die
arbeiter zu rufen
verstehe ich verstehe nichts ist alles
in fremden sprachen unsere häuser werden
von von fremden menschen gebaut unsere
tunnels der durchmesser tunnel da oben
in oerlikon die nähert es sind das sind
alles ausländer die das waren und
irgendwie wollen wir das nicht wahrhaben
oder kehren nachher auch jetzt mit einer
solchen abstimmung wieder zurück zu
diesem saison nicht dadurch dass man
sagt ja arbeiten könnte schon
familiennachzug gibt es nicht dinge die
hier eigentlich glaubten überwunden zu
haben was du sagtest es wird dass es
wird das rad wieder zurückgedreht und
und diese dass diese abhängigkeit und
diese durchdringung überhaupt von mit
mit leuten die nicht hier aufgewachsen
sind wir nicht von hier kommen die die
ist die ich da und ist eine rarität und
die die wird die können wir nicht
einfach mal auf andere ich möchte
vielleicht in einer schlusskurve das
thema ein bisschen nochmals auf sie
fokussieren
auch wie sie jetzt was beschrieben haben
also eine welt die sich verändert die
schweiz sie sich verändert die bleibt
mentalitäten die sich fest krank aber
trotzdem die welt wird sich weiter
entwickeln auch wenn sie einmal nicht
mehr ihren scharfen blick oder ihren
humorvollen blick auf dieses land werfen
ist das für sie ein problem
das wäre nicht mehr dabei sind also das
ist eine frage nach dem alter also im
alter das ich dinge auch willig ablösen
von von noah also ich meine es hat ja
auch nie irgendwie einen missionarischen
inhalt oder charakter hat sich die leute
missionieren wird also wenn jetzt als
nicht mehr passiert wenn man zurücktritt
und so dann müssen wir die leute einfach
ihrem schicksal überlassen was sie jetzt
selber anpacken und wie sie es lösen und
so aber studiert eigentlich gar nicht
vielleicht ist also schon ein bisschen
frage nach dem loslassen
bei ihnen sind dich das sehr schön immer
in diesem motiv das spazierengehen
sowohl auf wie sie das sagen und auch
das dann vielleicht eben nichts passiert
im kopf hat er nicht mit dem
diktiergerät oder mit dem land einfach
tieren zu lassen und das vielleicht auch
eine form der altersweisheit also oder
der alters fantasien aber der himmel
neidisch auf ihn wie er das macht mich
auch jetzt wieder wenn ich jetzt denke
loslassen es wird immer verrückter
werden wir bis jetzt habe ich mich zu
kommt in den nächsten 12 120 monaten
drückt also von loslassen
ich will es bereich gar nicht loslassen
bewusstlos lassen
es ist so interessant viel zu
interessanten du machst das gut
die schweiz könne das auch ohne uns ja
schon aber ich habe gehört afrika nicht
ziehen zusammen engagiert in einem
hilfswerk für afrika velos für afrika
was sie politisch weiterhin dynamisch
haltung bedauerlich eine zwanziger hatte
um sind die nächsten gegner
afrika
dann fahren wir mit elektrovelos daran
hindern in china das würde china haben
alle elektrovelo das ist ein motto wer
mit benzinmotor überhaupt nicht mehr
ganz ruhiger vergehen da kommen 30 40
auf einem will und so waren alle
elektrisch dafür sie ganz zum schluss
ganz kurz eine frage fragen die ihr sohn
im film von wies ihnen gestellt hat
nämlich die frage nach dem nicht
gelebten leben ganz kurz was hätte
hätten sie gemacht wenn sie noch mal
wechseln können überhaupt gar nichts
anderes überhaupt nicht das war so eine
interessante und spannende wegen tumor
voll und sagt nico getan und bin gesund
dabei geblieben
ich würde gar nichts anderes mache ich
auch weil ich bei der post gibt auch das
war gut auch das hat mir gut getan
rückblickend wird bekommt das was man
gemacht hat die stärkere logik aus dass
man nicht gemacht hat
also sagt man sich gerne ist in ordnung
so wie es gelaufen ist und das sage ich
eigentlich auch in bezug auf mich es gab
viele abzweigungen die ich hätte nehmen
können und die sicher auch interessant
gewesen wären und die die einen anderen
lebenslauf ergeben haben
aber die die kann ich mehr ausdenken
darüber kann ich vielleicht meinen
nächsten rumreiten erholt dass steinberg
vielen dank für das gespräch
dann habt ihr auch mehr
[Musik]